let's go to the neck deal with it is
anybody else ever had the spinning
reaction
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and
today I'm joined by the man of a
thousand and four holds Chris Jericho
he's a six-time world champion wrestler
with 27 years in the game a best-selling
author and host of the peoples podcast
talk as Jericho owned his metal band
Fozzy just released its seventh studio
album it's called Judas and surveill
Baldauf Chris welcome to the show first
of all it was very smooth really he just
follow me everywhere I go and announce
Mia into the room like that
that is big praise because I from a guy
like you and they respect the mic skills
the people's podcast that's good I might
use that I've already gained something
today from being here with you and that
might be it Chris Jericho how are you
like hot food I am the worst hot food
guy ever so I'm already questioning my
agents decision to put me here I'll tell
you what firing that son of a [ __ ] as
soon as this thing's done
[Music]
all right so I'm you just going downtown
to Chinatown on that one you're just
going right there's not even any Haas
and you're just like barbaric is a game
of Thrones or something geez man
easy Ramsay Shan chokes on camera the
show ends it's not beat Shawn sometimes
you know does anyone know the Heimlich
anybody be okay do ya yeah a couple
tears on your face yeah it's good a
little tangy all then here comes the
wave so it's not bad but if I'm thinking
that one one what's gonna happen to me
on wing nine I guess we'll find out so
before you ever made it to the
SummerSlam stage I understand that you
were a bouncer in Calgary Alberta Canada
is that where you birthed the walls of
Jericho were you ever put in a position
where you had to defend yourself well I
it was like Roadhouse when we came to
this bar well that was like a real bad
biker bar and they a SAP assembled this
you know crew of guys to kind of clean
the place up I used to just stand in the
back for the deejay listen to music and
talk to girls I never fought anybody but
the one time there was a bunch of bikers
came in the counter last remnants and
the night ended and it was time for them
to leave and they wouldn't go so I said
you know can you please leave and I'm
like you have to beat me in an arm
wrestling contest what he didn't know
was I had learned his secret arm
wrestling trick from guy Cole Scott
Norton who was a farmer sin champion
basically you [ __ ] your wrist like this
you had your whole upper body to use it
was more leverage yes cause it's all
about your wrist when you do like this
so I suddenly did this to the big biker
he look like you notice about 300 pounds
a big beard and dude I beat his ass
quickly don't get the hell out of here
and they left
[Music]
I didn't know if it was like Kristen
Kristen a little bit hotter so you
always hear these stories about
comedians and musicians on the come-up
and how they're you know playing small
venues or in laundromats and living
inside of their cars but sometimes the
origin stories with wrestlers are even a
little bit darker can you talk to me
about the struggle during the Legion
Hall and Moose Lodge days it really
tests your will to be there do you
really want to do this you want to be a
wrestler okay there's seven people out
there that's hard anybody can have a
great show in front of a sold-out crowd
go out there and connect with seven
people but when I first started my first
match they wanted me to be cowboy Chris
Jericho and I'm a rocker and did the
thought of being a cowboy it was like
and this is just horrible what I'm gonna
do and how much was to be a cowboy I
don't be a cowboy
and I'm called this guy named Brett Como
he's a local guy call him presently want
me to go but was like just don't do it I
was like what don't do it like I really
have the choice so I went in there right
before my first match and told the
promoter I'm not being cowboy Chris
Jericho now I'm a 19 year old nobody if
someone said that to me it'd be oh
really you're gonna be the female cowboy
Chris Jericho and we're gonna put fake
boobs on yeah and you know the chaps
with no ass in them but the guys like
okay don't do it then but the first
program ever says cowboy Chris Jericho
from Casper Wyoming nothing gets the
five people from Casper but never been
there before and definitely up from
there this one is OK for me too it's
we're in the front half Chris we're in
the front half don't talk down to me I'm
just an apartment
besides Shawn Michaels who's your
favorite wrestler of all time but Shawn
Michaels is my favorite as an opponent
as a performer I was a big ricky the
dragon' steamboat fan when I was growing
up Steve Austin was great the rock was
great but Hogan for whatever reason like
if you walked in this room right now
everybody be like oh my god like you
can't believe it which is what I always
tried to model myself after not him but
being larger than life as a wrestler
I loved Freddie Mercury and Paul Stanley
and David Lee Roth I wanted to be those
guys within the wrestling ring it took
the same characters that using rest
so from rock and roll it's all very
symbiotic it's a circle it's a very big
circle and it's like it's mad you'll
hear let me say this lot it's about
connecting with the audience if you can
connect with the audience whether it's
music rustling stand-up comedy ballet
whatever it is you'll always have a gig
and you'll always be successful with a
cheetah on it mm-hmm
like he took an extra bite they've been
doing this for hundred percent episode
you still just want to eat the wings I'm
just I'm about the craft that I'm a
little hungry things don't always go as
planned in the ring when you think about
all the times that things have gone
sideways is there a story that stands
out the work to match on Raw last year
with a guy called Neville and just from
a simple it's called a humorous : you
slide between someone's legs like you
hey I'm a wrestler I don't remember what
the movie spelled it's sly-jay so quick
it's a baseball slide you baseball slide
it's two guys is five wholesome fight
yeah exactly uh and he'd be basically
like broke his ankle shattered his knee
Shin whatever the hell it was he got up
and he did a couple more moves and I was
like man the timing is bad I mean while
he was still doing all this stuff with
one leg because was broke and he's like
you gotta we got to just call this match
so I go to the referee I start yelling
at him like you know cuz I'm trying to
get him to disqualify me so I'm yeah but
he doesn't know that the guy is hurt
okay so I'm like you know don't you talk
to me that way and I push her over in
the valleys like right I'll go ring the
bell and as I'm pushing her me don't
push me and I would we start arguing but
y'all had each other cuz he doesn't know
he's hurt and he thinks that I'm pushing
and making him look like a [ __ ] I'm
getting mad because he's not calling
them the match I am starting to push him
around like a [ __ ] and he's like turns
into Napoleon Chi starts pushing me back
we're literally [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you this is on Raw live TV with no
beeping one of the guys in the groin
I'm the one who's hurt don't forget
about me so yeah it was a drag and it
always sucks when when when one of your
guys gets hurt in a match but it does
happen you know it's it's it's it's not
ballet is the term that I liked
is this your guys's own we have to now
I'm gonna line up now they taking us to
the next land uprising over
[Music]
you maybe have been under estimating my
spicy food powers because this is a bet
this whole time Chris this holds up my
whole life
alright so every crane segment on our
show called explain that Graham what we
do is we do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll just show you
the picture and then you can tell me the
bigger is just like a way to recite in
the menu I'm slowly getting to the point
where you just pull a string and then
it's just gonna play pretty soon you're
gonna be replaced by an app laptop
please Wow okay yeah big things over
here at Hollywood all right first things
first
now if that isn't the coolest picture of
all time I live in Tampa and down the
street from my house a billionaire lives
there as obviously duh
so Arnold was coming to his house to do
a fundraiser so we go talking and he
wants to smoke a cigar yeah it's kind of
like this I'll smoke a cigar with you
Arnold because no one else is gonna know
who else is too scared to smoke a cigar
cuz the beats Scout yelled us by their
wives I'm like a hot smoke a cigar with
you man I have no problem I don't know
if you've ever had a real specimen when
you start getting it down it starts
getting you high like I started getting
buzzed and that's like Arnold like dude
I'm starting to get [ __ ] high goes I
know why do you think I smoked Wow
there's another one this is a real throw
X we had a show in Honolulu Bruce Willis
was there filming a movie I can remember
skull maybe hearts war heart of darkness
or some kind of movie where it was like
a jungle movie where he's film in Hawaii
and this is when Rocky was first
starting to get into Hollywood so Bruce
came to our show they were friends so
Bruce is in the front row and rock
throws me outside and I stopped at my
stuff rock down I go in Wilson's I'm
like you know Hudson Hawk sucks it's a
terrible movie so uh rock hits me and he
grabs me from behind
and he goes Bruce hit him and he stands
up and I'm like okay so he's either
gonna punch me in the face or slap me
and like I can take it no problem
whatever so I'm like I got my jaw
clenched and I'm ready to go and he goes
in headbutts me in the chest
like the most untaught move ever
and I remember thing was i how am I
supposed to sell this they selling
rustling like I can't even register but
people are going nuts so it's like ah my
heart is murmuring oh you just give me a
regular heartbeat
this one is tangy mm-hmm maybe my first
class of sip of milk you know that um
the human stomach can't drink a gallon
of milk it's impossible for the stomach
yeah so I did it pilot for show called
Ebaum's world which was a website that
had all videos now so you just go
passing your mom's world's clinic oh so
they were gonna do a show they wanted me
to host it so I went and did a of the
pilot and the guy came on tried to drink
a thing milk in the video and threw up
it was long as I can do that I used to
drink so much milk when I was a kid I
can do it so give me a gallon of milk I
start drinking it half gone in two
minutes easy second half like eating
like chalk so bad and every sip is just
closer to death but you know what I
drank that whole thing boom I went on
the king of milk drinking and then I
projectile threw up all over the guy's
face it was like Monty Python I'm the
king of milk drinking you sucked at the
hoof boom Oh hit the cameraman it was
like they're like a hose shooting across
the room cuz it's just like someone it's
my stomach and I think there's like ten
giant ropes of this milk coming out Dom
we got it we got a cap Chris at a glass
and a half okay accidentally healthy
intentionally delicious less healthy
a little bit hot I can't imagine the
type of training and diet regimen you
have to have to be able to succeed in
professional wrestling but I'm also very
interested in the bravado fueled mic
skills who is your trash talk Mount
Rushmore who are the top four of all
time in your opinion well I mean
obviously Rock has to be in there Steve
Austin was a great talker for sure seam
is really good sometimes he gets a
little bit immature kids stuff type
stuff but he's really good as well it's
hard like those ones jump into mind
instantly it's always that fourth spot
that's done yeah because you know who
you fill with I mean Hulk Hogan was
great because at the time in the 80s he
was the best problem when you believed
everything he said one time he compared
his tricep to Ronald Reagan cuz Ronald
Reagan is just like I don't bomb some
Russians or some things like I see the
four-lane socket coming up Reagan's try
I see the stock of bananas in his
shoulders just like this when he does
this it looks like bananas cuz there's
so much rip is it more fun for you to
play the heel it's a lot easier to make
people hate you at first then to make
them like you but then once they start
hating you it's very hard to keep that
going is there a pop cultural figure
someone who's not in the wrestling world
that you think would make a great heel
in professional wrestling
I loved Dwight Schrute in the office of
just being like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
not tough but just that guy you're just
like this guy's just a jerk that's a
great character in wrestling or anything
you have to fall into the character
become the character you know I've seen
Ozzy backstage at Fester's guy can
barely walk he looks like a fragile old
man as soon as he crosses the sight line
to where the crowd is
he becomes Ozzie clap your [ __ ] ass
think how crazy and he does and Alice
Cooper is like that the nicest guy you
can meet but on stage it's like that
serial killer [ __ ] you know those are
the characters that I was like because
they're larger than life
this is about one loved one skin mm-hmm
but yeah a bit about one I should have
taken a small bite my Eddie Van Halen
powers are gone that [ __ ] sucks and
you think it goes away but it doesn't
you're in the soup is coming it's like a
wrestling you sell and if you really get
hurt you don't wanna play anymore I
don't wanna play anymore and also makes
me have to spit - do you think I was
gonna throw up there so you're getting
that sort of cheek watering Jack Daniel
situation you know I move your tongue
they remove it hurts uh-huh so there you
go
bit of closes well that for Instagram
you know as heated as it might be in the
ring or on the mic maybe once you're off
the clock
you guys are best of friends and I know
that sometimes that he can boil over
into the locker room or wherever when
you think about all the feuds that you
had which one held its heat inside the
ring and outside of it that's wig out um
Triple H 2002 we didn't like each other
I think we're almost pitted against each
other in a lot of ways I take my jacket
off so let it go you guys knew that
that's why you might be inside too
[ __ ] diabolical we had great
chemistry great matches I just didn't
like him he didn't like me and there was
no falseness so now we love him great
guy that's good enough deal with it what
was the greatest Royal Rumble the
greatest locker room elimination match
the greatest match that the cameras
didn't catch I've had a couple
altercations with guys much larger than
me
and both think I'm [ __ ] crazy and I
guess I am and thankfully they didn't
eat my head and kill me but yeah those
those are two for me
Goldberg and one with Brock Lesnar and
we'll leave it at that so there you go
now you [ __ ] happy they make you meet
this stuff it might be next to usual
with liquid reach no one in
my lips are burning now uh-huh
is NY ever puked on the show except what
does it make you puke have it Martin
garrix might have but we don't know for
sure
it's lose Adam he's a big DJ of course
he puked DJ's are stupid
how are the wrestling fans different in
Japan compared to st. said quiet
respectfully watching when you first go
anything my soxhlet why is there no
reaction whatsoever they'll start
reacting when when you start doing the
finishing false moves at the end but
they're respectfully watching because to
them it's a real craft the performance
the performance if you do a nice hold a
technical little wrestling I think
they'll all clap if I take you to the
ropes and you know break you they'll
clap for you because that's what you're
supposed to do you are honorable you
followed the rules stuff that would
never happen here I love Japan have been
there 60 times I remember the first time
I went to Japan there was a kickboxer
that was turned into a wrestler and he
was kicking me as hard as he [ __ ]
could he was killing me so I want a sign
grabbed a chair cuz it was a hardcore
wrestling chemical fmw I just hit him in
the [ __ ] head as hard as I could
after that he was fine
there you go this garbage can and
garbage bag will be on sale later on
eBay just in case any of you are looking
for some Jericho spit so this is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to has anybody
ever turn that down yeah give me a name
Andy Cohen Andy Cohen you host that um a
show on Bravo he ducked the dab I put
somebody that I've heard of no one
you've ever heard of his duck to dab I'm
actually shaking a little bit that just
looks [ __ ] all right it's been a
wonderful ride grass thanks I'll see you
on the other side
I'm sure Kevin Hart was having some
problems telling his little jokes after
eight that I need some chapstick is why
I need everything some milk flavored
chapstick swimming this Motorhome yeah
okay so now that the bomb is seeping
into your soul you have death sauce
biting at your brain and then the last
dab finding its spot as well I'd like to
know which one of these hot sauces is
making the list what's your message for
the hot sauce makers who think that they
can get on top of Chris Jericho well you
did congratulations
uh yeah the Volta bomb was the worst
and I'll say Queen Majesty Scott spawn
and ginger was the most pleasant
I enjoyed that one I might actually buy
a ball that and use it on my future
wings so I apologize it's probably
pretty disgusting but I don't care it
you guys haven't eaten this stuff and I
have and right now it's just see how to
survive so there you go
stay on top of it sorry if I'm not
impressing about with my lack of couthe
here on hot ones on the first we feast
Network somebody give me that belt that
Joe liPuma spent $400 on because this
man is a champion Chris Jericho this
camera this camera but this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life if we're gonna do this
let's do it right
[Music]
the bomb I am now giving you the
championship of hot sauces thanks man
look at this camera look at in that
camera and all those other cameras if
you want to know what I'm doing just
Google me it was a so fuzzy record or
it's know as a four-letter word Chris
Jericho's Rock n wrestling rager at sea
and in this world with all the [ __ ] that
goes on if I can put a smile on
somebody's face or give someone a good
tune to listen to at the top down or
read a book that gives them a little bit
of courage to try something different
then then at the end of the day my my
mission is accomplished
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans a
quick heads up the second annual complex
con is coming to Long Beach California
November 4th and 5th and you know first
we feast and hot ones are gonna be in
the building there's gonna be a live hot
ones taping we're gonna be doing a panel
with my buddies Andy Milonakis and Matty
Matheson the last dab will be for sale
it's a whole thing
total circus hope to see you there